this video was made possible by Ray Khan
get top quality comfortable and
surprisingly affordable wireless earbuds
for 15% off at bi recon comm slash
Wendover just about once every three
days somewhere in the world a large
commercial passenger plane crashes most
of these are not hugely catastrophic
because most of these are fatality free
of the 1070 recorded crashes in the
2010s decade only 112 proved fatal even
of these the vast majority of passengers
survived an average fatal crash in fact
half of all deaths from airline crashes
in the previous decade are from just 12
incidents that's to say most fatal
aircraft accidents are not the kinds you
see in movies the kinds where there are
few or no survivors most are more minor
incidents with just one or two or a few
more unlucky victims the industry though
does not view them that way the truth is
that people fear airplanes an irrational
amount so in order for air travel to be
as commonplace as it is they require a
standard of safety far higher than any
other method of transport safety and
profitability go hand in hand for
airlines despite this though accidents
are effectively an inevitability for any
of the largest airlines statistically
some of these largest airlines are also
some of the safest yet none are 100%
safe therefore with enough flying an
accident will happen all 10 of the
world's largest airlines have had fail
accidents in their histories and so with
this level of inevitability airlines
must have a strictly defined plan for
what to do after one of their airplanes
crash so let's say an accident happens
this will almost certainly have
something to do with landing or taking
off the overwhelming majority of
accidents involved the runway however if
an accident is fatal it is much more
likely that it has to do with a loss of
control in flight or a controlled crash
into terrain runway accidents represent
more than ninety percent of accidents
but only account for 25
and of fatal accidents the airline
really never is the first responder to
an accidents that is typically
firefighters and other emergency
personnel but as soon as word of an
accident reaches them the airline will
begin to mobilize almost every airline
out there will have what's called a go
team this is a group of people typically
working at the Airlines headquarters who
train to be part of the crisis response
function on top of their ordinary jobs
with larger airlines this go team can be
comprised of as many as hundreds of
individuals filling a huge variety of
functions larger long-haul airlines
might also have smaller teams comprised
of people working at their out stations
who can more quickly get to crash sites
while the main team travels from a
headquarters now each airline will have
different procedures and protocols but
there are loose standards adopted by all
typically within three to four hours of
a crash an airline's go team will have
assembled and taken off from the
headquarters airport usually a standby
flight crew and aircraft would be used
for this dedicated flight with them they
bring a go kit considering accidents can
happen quite literally anywhere this
would include all sorts of things like
satellite communications equipment food
water cooking equipment personal
protective equipment warm clothing tents
generators tools and more the team's
personnel are typically split up into
dealing with three main areas crisis
support humanitarian support and
communications each of these would
likely be split up into a forward team
and rear team if the crash occurs in a
remote location for example the forward
team including the most essential
members of each of the larger teams
would likely go to the crash site and
set up a literal base camp using the
equipment and the go cats meanwhile the
rear team might set up in the nearest
town with accommodations and facilities
at the crash site a triage area is set
up away and upwind from the aircraft
wreckage this might be done by some of
the crisis response go team members or
by emergency personnel their individuals
would be split up into three groups
deceased injured and uninjured
the deceased and injured would typically
be cared for by firefighters medics and
other emergency personnel whereas the
airline go team would likely deal with
the uninjured
passengers the rear go team will have
meanwhile set up a survivor reception
center usually at a nearby hotel and
arrange transportation to that site the
largest group in the go team is
typically the humanitarian assistance
team which is made up of volunteers
among the airlines is customer service
staff flight attendants Airport agents
and others by grouping the passengers
together in one facility the airline
separates them from media and
centralizes them for investigatory
interviews and support functions the
aircraft's surviving crew will typically
be dealt with by a different team which
would bring them to a different facility
than the passengers which is recommended
for both legal and public relations
reasons another subset of the
humanitarian assistance team will set up
a facility for friends and family of the
passengers near the accident site they
might also set up a separate facility at
the origin or destination of the flight
where large clusters of friends and
family might be the individuals there
would be provided with updates as a
group and then would be sorted so that
friends and families of survivors would
be brought to an area to reunite whereas
others might be broken the news that
their family member or friends has died
the role of these family assistance
centers is amplified in the case of
crashes where there is a significant
long-term search-and-rescue operation as
is often the case with crashes into the
ocean in the case of the Malaysian
Airlines flight 370 disappearance for
example the Family Assistance centers
were in operation for two months the
passenger and Family Assistance centers
might need to house hundreds and
thousands of individuals respectively so
the setup and functions of these is
likely to find prior to any accidents
airlines will decide for example that
they need a general lounge a faith area
a psychological assistance area a press
area a phone and internet area and more
and more beforehand and then it's just
about deciding which area goes where
once a location for the facility is
identified with this and all other
response efforts actions are procedure
alized so that each member of the team
knows what to do even in a fast-moving
chaotic scenario away from the crash
site Airlines will set up a crisis
command center in their headquarters
including executives from each aspect of
the airline's operations in order to
coordinate their response in addition a
call center is often quickly set up and
staffed to answer
questions from family and friends of
passengers and the media this is just a
small part of the overall communications
effort though because more than anything
else probably the best thing an airline
can do for themselves after an accident
is communicate that's why the third
primary aspect of a go team
beyond crisis and humanitarian response
is communications after one of their
aircraft crash an airline is concerned
with business continuity they're
concerned with how they'll emerge from
the other end of the incidents and so
the communications have to be strategic
crisis communications is a subset of
public relations intended to minimize
reputational damage after an incident at
a company within this Airlines want to
be sure that to the extent possible they
are able to control the narrative that
means they need to communicate fast and
loudly to drown out any other noise so
they put communications go team members
on site to be able to disseminate
accurate information as fast as possible
to the media survivors and family and
friends there will also however be a
team back at the airline HQ that will
have to make more methodical strategic
communications decisions now at the end
of the day there ends up being two main
options for responding to an incident
accepting blame or deferring blame
academic research into the matter shows
that taking responsibility early
typically leads to a better public
response and actually tends to decrease
the size of settlements that end up
getting paid out however the risk one
runs is that by accepting responsibility
this can open up a company to legal
consequences therefore despite
overwhelming evidence that it is not the
prudent move organizations will often
defer responsibility until it is
absolutely certain that it is indeed
their fault if it is absolutely sure
that an accident is not the airline's
fault such as in the case of aircraft
manufacturing defects deferring blame
can actually shift public sentiment to
position the airline as a victim
themselves but the evidence for such
cases typically only becomes conclusive
after years of investigation so in the
immediate aftermath of a crash it can
seem to the public as evading
responsibility there for deciding
whether to take or shift blame is
the tough choice for airlines one of the
recent case studies in crisis
communication involves Southwest
Airlines flight 1308 in 2018 shortly
upon reaching crews after its departure
from LaGuardia Airport its left engine
failed and fragments were flung into the
aircraft fuselage with that one window
was broken and due to the rapid
decompression and fast-moving debris the
passenger sitting next to that window
died from her injuries the aircraft
ended up landing safely and there were
only minor injuries among the other
passengers but for Southwest this was a
major crisis it was the first aircraft
accident fatality in the u.s. since 2009
and their first ever Southwest
essentially took responsibility right
away giving each passenger five thousand
dollars in cash and one thousand dollars
in flight credits they also very quickly
issued empathetic personable statements
which combined with their prior positive
reputation were effective in persuading
the public that they were truly sorry
the company also paused all marketing
for a month to let the sensitive
situation fade away in public discourse
so all told this incident and its
response cost them about 100 million
dollars in the end after the
investigation was fully completed it was
determined that it probably wasn't
Southwest's fault the accident was
caused by a tiny largely invisible
fatigue fracture on one of the engines
fan blades Southwest followed all
maintenance and inspection protocols for
this aircraft but for some reason these
didn't catch the issue therefore the
protocols were updated after the fact
Southwest went the expensive yet
effective crisis communication method if
they had deferred blame they might have
been able to lose less money but if in
the end it was found that they should
bear some blame this could result in
significant reputational damage in the
immediate response to a plane crash the
incentives of the airline and victims
are often aligned because the public
responds positively to positive
treatment of the victims it is later on
though where incentives increasingly
splits victims often look for
compensation airlines look to minimize
their financial responsibility by that
time the public is no longer interested
in a plane
crash crashes are interesting when
there's a burning pile of debris not
when a bunch of lawyers are sitting in a
courtroom therefore that's exactly why
airlines put a huge disproportionate
amount of claiming money and effort into
the phase of response with the burning
pile of debris it's the most effective
use of those resources and at the end of
the day two airlines airplane crashes
are a financial problem if you're
anything like me you listen to music
podcasts and audiobooks constantly while
working that means that you probably
have earbuds in for many hours per day
so it's worth making sure the ones you
use are good having now tried them I can
attest that ray cons wireless earbuds
are good they have great audio quality
and are super comfortable yet they also
stayed in perfectly while I was out on a
run which was impressive their everyday
e25 s have six hours of play time
seamless bluetooth pairing a compact
noise-isolating fit and most
impressively they cost about half as
much as comparable premium wireless
earbuds on top of that they're an even
better deal considering they're giving
Wendover viewers 15% off by going to buy
reagan comm / mind / and you'll be
supporting the channel with your
purchase